technology and I see that there are a
bunch of
questions that have been
saved up here
um you know I'm in the middle of a big
kind of History of Science Adventure
right now uh because I've been working
on the second world of thermodynamics
I've been working on the science of that
the sort of future science of that but
I've been going back because some of the
things I figured out about the future
science of that don't really agree with
the things that are part of the
conventional wisdom about the second law
and so I've been interested in well what
where did that conventional wisdom come
from and so I've been digging backwards
into the history of things and I will
say that I'm I'm still in the 1600s but
uh it's been interesting what I have
learned I mean I can share a few things
so once people have figured out what
heat was that heat was the microscopic
motion of molecules the second law got
formulated very quickly within 10 years
and it's pretty much its current basic
form and but figuring out what heat was
was a long story and so back in
Antiquity Democritus the epicureans
they had this idea that the world was
made of atoms these indivisible things
atoms in the void and they had kind of
this notion that there were two kinds of
things in the world atoms and the void
and there were people who said oh
um you know everything is just sort of a
Continuum of plenum
um and then there are people who were
talked about atoms it's interesting but
in our model of physics we finally get
to unify the notion of atoms and the
notion of the Void
um because in our model the things that
make up space are themselves atoms there
isn't just atoms embedded in in this
void of space I I also learned to think
recently about Descartes from the
beginning of the 1600s
um Descartes had this view of the world
in which everything was made of not
quite atoms but these vortices that the
the whole world was made up of of all
these little tiny vortices interacting
with each other one of the things that
Descartes believed is that you couldn't
have distance in space without there
being vortices in between those two
places but there was distance between in
other words that to have space be a
thing that you'd have to go through to
have to be vortices there that they
couldn't just be an empty void there
um and so that was a a that's
interesting because that's very much
what happens in our model of physics
that there isn't any distance between
two points in space unless there are
nodes in the hypergraph between one
point and another so this is actually
turns out to be a rather amusingly it's
sort of a Cartesian idea even though the
notion of coordinates that was another
Cartesian Descartes idea is something
that we issue in our model on the
grounds that what we're really dealing
with is just these these atoms of space
so to speak but any case the thing that
um
uh people thought about heat was they
thought there were these different kinds
of atoms you know the air water
um
uh
uh another one and fire as well as
quintessence
but fire they thought they were fire
atoms and they thought this is now a
Democritus uh you know 5th Century BC
was thinking that
um the uh uh that heat was the presence
of a lot of fire atoms and fire atoms
were spheres and spheres could kind of
get through other things and so this
sort of heat was able to sort of slide
between other other pieces of the world
other pieces of matter and could be so
that something that was hot here could
make something else hot here
so that was kind of their model but they
had a very strange sort of connection
there because they also thought that the
soul was made of fire atoms and that the
soul was the ultimate seat of all motion
that in order for things to move there
had to be a soul that was ultimately
moving those things and so they had this
kind of relationship between the soul
the notion of animals that could move
you know I think works better for
warm-blooded animals and the notion of
heat as a thing that was a disembodied
thing
so you know that was kind of the version
and Antiquity that heat is the motion of
little tiny corpuscles of fire little
fire atoms through the other
constituents of the world
well for 2 000 years people didn't
figure out anything better
and I I've been looking at the
Alchemists and so on the Alchemists
didn't even have a notion of gases they
knew about the air but they didn't talk
about gas as a thing distinct from air
and they knew that there were things
like Steam and so on they knew there was
Carbonic um gas carbon dioxide things
like that but they didn't really think
of a thing that was this notion of a gas
um and so I don't think the Alchemists
contributed anything to this and then we
get to the kind of uh early modern times
of
um you know we get to for example
Galileo and I just found a thing
yesterday from 1623 from Galileo in
which she's talking about heat and he
says heat is the result of tiny
corpuscles that transmit the Heat and he
says and when they get into us then they
excite our senses the tiny corpuscles
kind of um are things that kind of they
they they they we sense those corpuscles
as they move through us and he he notes
that when you have a glass thing smells
can't get out of the glass thing but
heat can and so he says they must be
very subtle atoms of heat to be able to
escape the glass thing in a way that a
smell cannot escape the gas thing
but um and he has a whole description
actually has an interesting description
that the very smallest
uh he thinks that the these these um
sort of atoms I don't think he calls
them corpuscles I think of um a fire
although I need to look at the Original
Latin because I'm not sure uh exactly
how I was just looking at translation
um which is always a dangerous thing to
do of course it's uh it only works if
you know the original language and I I
know probably enough Latin to be able to
to you know be able to tell whether the
translation is iffy
um and you have to understand that
translations translating things from
that period of time is a complicated
matter because the the concepts that we
have now like the concept of gas didn't
exist at that time and so the um uh
and that
um so you know if you are going to
translate a thing that Galileo said or
for example the notion of an atom at the
time of Galileo was different from the
notion of atom today so if you're going
to translate something Galileo wrote
It's Complicated whether you translated
into the terms of today or whether
you're trying to use some more neutral
terms which are then harder to
understand
um that don't directly connect with the
the terms that we use today but anyway
so Galileo
um
uh has this thing where he says maybe
these fire corpuscles when they're
broken down I couldn't really understand
what he was saying so I'm gonna go look
at the Latin and maybe I'll have a
better better luck there when they get
broken down enough they are no longer
caloric they are no longer heat they are
instead light
and what that relationship in in
Galileo's mind is I'm not quite sure
now it's interesting that Galileo has
this um uh
um
this kind of um really quite mechanistic
view of heat it's a quite a clean
description I mean it isn't quite right
but it's quite a clean description
Francis Bacon same time 1620-ish
has a whole thing about heat is motion
but it isn't really motion it's some
actually Galileo makes a comment about
this as well he says that heat is is
somehow related to motion it's relation
related to motion of these microscopic
things but it isn't the same thing when
you move a piece of iron around that
doesn't make it hot it's some other kind
of motion that happens inside the iron
now now bacon is a bit more abstract and
talks about heat and motion are somehow
the same thing and one can produce the
other and so on but it's all kind of
vague Galileo is much cleaner much more
sort of to the point even though he
doesn't quite get it right and he
doesn't really know how it works but
it's much better better presented so to
speak
now the thing I literally just uh uh
when I ran out of time last night was
studying was some Robert Boyle
um and Boyle you know developed Boyle's
Law of 1666-ish time frame I kind of
climbed a bunch of other people have
been working on the notion that air is
elastic that air is something that like
a material you can kind of crush it and
it is it is it behaves like a material
it also spreads out to fill a container
there have been a bunch of people who've
done experiments around the same time
I'm a hook Robert Hook was an assistant
of Robert Boyles I'm always uh have kind
of a I don't know much about Robert
Boyle I need to learn more about him but
I I sort of have a soft spot for him for
for one reason which is the the high
school that I went to a place called
Eaton college that was founded in 1450
or so in England
um it uh for a while I don't know if
it's still true but it listed uh on like
places like Wikipedia you know
scientists who went to eat in college
and for a while there was Robert Boyle
and then there was me with a like 350
year Gap or something which I just
thought was rather Charming I think
think they're others and I think that's
a that's an inadequately filled in list
but um that that was gave me a kind of
felt like a I had a personal connection
now I I actually was just looking up
Robert Boyle's life at Eaton college and
it was a definitely a little bit less
organized than it was by my time so to
speak but um
in any case Robert Boyle uh I believe
wrote about kind of what
well actually we should say something
about how the idea of a gas emerged
so as a guy I'm uh John Von Helmont
who was a Dutch Flemish physician and
philosopher those were combo uh
occupations in those days
um it was a physician who was very
opposed to kind of the Hippocrates Galen
tradition of of medicine which had been
this idea of uh kind of um these
elements that were just like kind of the
elements that everything was made of and
then that turned into the notion of
humors and um I don't know all of uh
kind of medicine from the Middle Ages
and so on and from Antiquity
um this notion of I mean that that led
to all of these bizarre medical uh sort
of treatments uh you know bleeding
things and and uh you know various kinds
of
fluids in US humans you know putting
more or getting less all this kind of
thing and it was all about sort of the
balance of these fluids of course they
had no idea that there were anything
microscopic wasn't wasn't understood at
that time and uh I mean I I have to say
I'm a little bit sort of sobered to
think of the Medical Treatments of today
how many of those will look like they
were bloodletting type treatments you
know we will say of them those were as
silly as the bloodletting treatments of
the 1600s were when um uh you know at
some point in the future but any case uh
Van Helmont
was a person who didn't really believe
in the the kind of approach to doctoring
that um had come from Galen and
Hippocrates from Antiquity and uh was
kind of fighting against that and one of
the things he did was he figured out
something which I haven't yet understood
very well about disease and gas and the
idea that you could breathe out you
breathe out of gas that's carbon dioxide
of some kind it's a different kind of
thing from what's in the air in general
and uh and those types of things and in
fact he coined the term the word gas and
there's a strained piece of etymology
because he uh the word chaos uh Chi
Alpha Omicron Sigma in Greek
um as a word that has now been
um turned into kind of this notion of
chaos and chaotic and and Randomness and
so on in in Greek I should say why is
this related to gas well it's related
gas because Van Helmont basically was
giving the the Dutch rendering or the
Flemish rendering of the word chaos Kaus
whatever whatever your favorite
pronunciation of ancient Greek which we
don't really know what it was
um was but anyway that rendered into
Dutch was gas and that's where that term
comes from SO gas is a term for chaos so
then a question you might ask is well
what did chaos and ancient Greek
actually mean and what it meant was
avoid it was the void in which for
example the atoms of Democritus lived in
fact I I need to look up unfortunately
very few of democracy I don't think any
democritus's original writing has
survived I think people um uh think um
theophrastus for example who's mostly
known for his Botanical works I think he
talks about some of what democratus said
and other people talk about Democritus
and lucibus and the other epicureans I
don't know how much has survived I don't
know whether one can read what you know
the atoma the indivisible a
Toma to
do I know my Greek Tomo I would guess
was the first person singular I mean of
of um to cut and um of um and so you
know an atom is something which cannot
be cut
um but I would like to know actually
what the translation of void in Greek is
I I presume it's the same word chaos and
so
the um that word means kind of avoid an
empty space well probably an empty space
unless you're Descartes where the void
is full of vortices but um and that it
also had got this notion of kind of
formless primordial formlessness
and I think that's where in the English
translation things like you know Genesis
in the Bible has you know things were
without form uh what is it
um
I'm not forgetting but but uh well you
know void and without form so to speak
and this notion of sort of primordial
chaos which I think also exists in Greek
mythology
um was uh uh this this notion of sort of
a a a a formless nothingness sort of and
that was the thing that turned into the
word for gas
so okay now we're in 1666 and um uh
uh I guess
do I know my history well enough is that
the time when the English Civil War was
in um
no that was the time of the plague that
was the time of um uh yeah but anyway so
uh Boyle is hanging out with his sister
Catherine Jones who seems to have been
quite a contributor at his activities
um and uh doing experiments on on air
um and trying to figure out what air is
now somewhere uh because I found a bunch
of quotes of this Boyle talks about two
theories for what air might be two
theories for what it might be made of
one that it is a fixed array of
corpuscles with little springy things
between them so it's kind of like a
crystal of corpuscles with springs
between them which somehow expand out
into the size of a container
um that's Theory number one Theory
number two is it's some kind of vortices
that bump into each other in a bit more
like what Descartes was talking about
and um Boyle I gather did not really
have a preference between these two
um but I need to find what he actually
wrote and unfortunately I was trying to
read the skeptical chemist yesterday
which is Boyle's most famous work except
it's called the skeptical keemness you
know it's in it's an Old English and uh
uh it's pretty hard to understand at
least for me you almost have to
translate it out of the old old English
form
um into uh
um into Modern English and it's much
worse than for example Newton's Optics
which were written in what the 1710s or
something which are quite understandable
for for somebody with you know with
Modern English so to speak any case and
I don't know maybe Boyle was was writing
backwards to a to a period earlier than
him
but in any case the um uh so anyway
that's the claim about what he said now
old Isaac Newton got into the ACT 1687
there's a part of the principia where he
talks about gases it's a little bit
obscure I was just trying to read it
yesterday and in fact what he's
discussing is something very you know
scientifically fancy which is what does
a sphere of gas do under mutual gravity
and he knows it's going to be a sphere
he knows that that when you have just a
Big Blob of stuff according to his
universal law of gravity it will all get
pulled together as as happens with stars
and so on anyway he knew this but he had
to know kind of he wanted to know kind
of what a a gas was and what he thought
was it was kind of like the choice
number one of of Boyle of um kind of the
the the array of corpuscles and that
between them was a force uh an inverse
with the distance I didn't do the math
yet none of Square Force law but an
inverse one over r four slaw as opposed
to one over r squared Force law and
apparently he claimed he could get
Boyle's Law pressure times volume it
score constant for a gas from that
derivation of course in the end that
derivation turns out to I mean that
whole thing turns out to be nonsense
because what's really causing pressure
on a gas is the the impact of molecules
on the walls of the gas which is
something that it seems that Daniel
Bernoulli worked out in maybe 1738
um and uh uh again I haven't I haven't
read his stuff yet
um
and that's something where so that was
sort of the beginning of kinetic theory
but by the way I'm just moving forwards
a little bit
um into uh uh the 1800s sort of the big
news of that time were steam engines and
obviously steam engines are all about
taking heat and making mechanical work
something that people had done you know
hero of Alexandria had done a little bit
of that kind of thing back in Antiquity
and there'd been a kind of a history of
trying to you know take Heat
and you know produce steam make it push
things and so on but um uh eventually
Thomas newcomer had this sort of
practical closed-loop system for for and
first using steam engine to pump water
out of mines and then much later on was
James Watt and uh uh the sort of fancier
steam engine and Notions of Governors
and control systems and things like this
but um
in any case the the practicality of the
steam engine was sort of the big thing
of the of the beginning of the 1800s and
earn a big contributor to the Industrial
Revolution in the end
um but uh uh something which was the
kind of the the uh wow it's exciting
it's kind of like like some people might
say about the metaverse today except in
those days it was steam engines and you
know when you read the marketing
material so to speak for steam engines
it's really quite amusing because it's
so uh breathlessly the world is you know
the future is is amazing and the steam
engine is going to transform the world
and so on and it is it is so amazingly
like the marketing material you you read
about new technologies today uh the
steam engine did work out of course not
all technologies that are breathlessly
described work out but the steam engine
um one of the questions was okay you're
making a steam engine you've got all
these inventions for how you make Steam
Engines what's the most efficient steam
engine you can make
and that was a trap called sarikano a
French
um
engineer basically who had come from
this rather political family that was
you know in favor out of favor at
different times as Napoleon came in and
came out and so on
um and came back in again
um but in any case study Kano 1824 I
think
um
wrote this thing in French
um English translation is on the Motive
Power of heat
and he invented this notion of the Kano
cycle this idea it's actually fairly
interesting and I need to understand it
better but but I think what he really
invented was the notion of the abstract
machine I'm not sure that notion had
existed before I think people had had
the idea of a concrete machine now I'm
not sure if this is right because when
we think about clocks for example there
is an abstract purpose to a clock when
we think about things for like clocks
for finding longitude things like that
there is an abstract purpose to those
things but I think the description of of
what they of how they work was very much
and there's this Cog and there's this
Cog and so on maybe maybe not I mean you
know Galileo's last Works around 1640 or
so were about pendulums and in a sense
that's sort of an abstract machine as
well because you can kind of describe
the pendulum and it's swinging without
having to say uh kind of what the um uh
you know whether the pendulum has a has
a a plant at the end of it or whether it
has a piece of gold or what it is it
doesn't matter it just is the mass of
the pendulum so so maybe there's maybe
Galileo had had sort of the Precedence
on this but in terms of heat Kano was
the guy who kind of tried to make an
abstract theory of how heat engines
would work and and those kinds of things
but he didn't really his work was not
widely known at the time and it really
took until the 1850s for things to get
picked up and people to start really
talking about
um
um
the uh uh about the sort of kinetic
theory of of heat and so on and I mean
what had happened before that this
logiston Theory and the notion of
caloric and the notion of in fact even
Kano still believed in caloric believed
that heat was a substance like the
substance that Galileo talks about where
it's like little corpuscles of fire or
something are heat and they can flow
through things and there's there's sort
of pieces of heat that flow around now I
think again I've not really looked at
them maybe I should uh postpone talking
about this until I have is is uh Fourier
um Joseph whatever he was for AI from um
1807 or so 1804 1804 I think originally
was um the person who started looking at
the transmission of heat
in uh in materials now it's worth
remembering that 1804 is really late in
the development of of calculus you know
people like Euler have been around you
know Gauss was active Gauss was writing
all kinds of fancy things so there was
no lack of fanciness and understanding
differential equations all this kind of
thing what Fourier did was to apply this
differential equation technology to heat
which people hadn't really had a kind of
a mathematical discussion of now I mean
one of the things that it also made that
difficult was how do you measure heat
well you measure temperature how do you
measure temperature who's ever measure
temperature well Galileo was actually
the first person to make a um
uh a thermometer he made a thing called
a thermoscope which is something that
basically liquid expands and then it
comes into some it's kind of like a you
know people had fountains that were
based on this kind of principle of
liquid when when heated expands and gets
pushed up through a tube and then kind
of fountains down and so on there have
been examples of this in Antiquity but
Galileo kind of tried to make that into
kind of an instrument I think this is
now in the um
1605-ish time frame into some kind of
instrument that would sort of measure
heat measure temperature you know it is
funny that I I'm pretty sure I have to
look this up that the the central
England temperature
um time Series starts in 1650 so that's
the longest running kind of information
about about temperature and for climate
studies and so on that exists and it
didn't start that long it was less than
50 years after the first idea of a
thermometer came into existence
so
in any case Galileo kind of began this
process of having a measurable concept
of temperature it didn't help that back
in the day I think there were like 35
different scales of temperature that
were in use and that sort of
standardized to Fahrenheit and Celsius
and then later kelvins
um but uh you know I think that that was
a bit of a downer in terms of the the
development of theories of these things
was you know everybody was quoting you
know temperatures of things in in weird
different scales but uh you know Fourier
I think
um you know apply math to heat was kind
of his thing and then
we get to the 1850s and maybe I'll talk
about that another time where uh we
really get the development of kinetic
theory
um in the hands of first Rudolph
clausius
and then um uh following soon thereafter
James Clerk Maxwell William Thompson
later Lord Kelvin
um
uh later on comes Ludwig boltzmann and
also Josiah Willard Gibbs a U.S presence
and these things that was more in the
1870s and so on but um uh it was kind of
this this really it took only a modest
number of years
for um
for this kind of notion of the of the
first law of thermodynamics law of
consolation of energy which was the
clausiest production and the concept of
entropy which was the clausiest
production uh clausius also had he had a
lot of names for things so he had
another name ergal was a name that I
just learned which was his name for
potential energy
um and he had so he entropy was a winner
ergal was not a winner uh this Viva the
name for kinetic energy was also not a
winner but um kazias was the person who
developed this you know entropy is equal
to Q over t d q over t d s is equal to
DQ over T and so on and that was the
whole development from there any case
this is uh some history I've been
studying
um and uh
um
I I maybe I'll tell some more of the
story another time I will say that some
of the people involved in this uh like
James Maxwell I become a huge James
Clark Maxwell fan I think I maybe
mentioned that before but I every every
week now as I've been studying things
related to him I'm more and more of a
fan it was a very clear writer and very
clear thinker
um unfortunately died at the age of 48
so didn't wasn't didn't have as many
years to do science as he might have
done
um but uh and he also wrote about just a
a wonderful diversity of different
topics
and um uh just a uh an interesting Chap
and anyway maybe another time I can I
can talk in more detail about and maybe
somebody can remind me about that
um and I'll probably know more the next
time I'm I'm talking about him
all right let's see there was a question
here from Paul
bid Einstein ever attempt to quantize
space-time as opposed to treating it as
a continuous medium
uh the answer is yes
um by the way all these people talking
about molecular theories of things they
are I mean Maxwell for example Maxwell
contributed an article to Encyclopedia
Britannica Maxwell was hanging in um in
Scotland at the time and Encyclopedia
Britannica originated in Edinburgh and
uh he was um he contributed the the
article about atom to encycloped
Britannica and it's still reproduced in
the 1911 one for example which is a very
famous edition of the inside pretty
Britannica and it's really it's very
good it's um it has a very nice
historical description in fact I was
about to go back and check and look at
it because I I think it's a better
historical description that I found
elsewhere about what the epicureans
thought and so on but anyway Maxwell
um talks about the argument between the
corpuscularians the people who believe
that in discreetness and the people who
believe in a plenum
um which is was the old name for a
continuum uh and he talks about the
different kinds of evidence that you
might get for for corpuscular kinds of
things versus Continuum kinds of things
and it is deeply Charming to me that
what Maxwell says you could simply
translate when he's talking about Mata
you could translate it into talking
about space and you would have exactly
the things that people told me for years
about the fact that beliefs of mine that
that space in space-time would
ultimately turn out to be discreet
couldn't be right and you find the exact
same discussion back in the 1800s people
saying couldn't possibly be right that
water is made of discrete things
couldn't possibly be it's a plenum it's
not and people had all these Arguments
for that uh and and you know heat was an
interesting case because that was also
thought to be a Continuum of a plenum
kind of thing made of caloric fluid
um and you know heat turned out to be a
little bit more of a subtle question I
mean heat wasn't and same with what we
believe space to be in in our model of
physics it's not like oh there's just a
bucket of space here it's that there's
it's a more complicated construct that
is a continually changing construct that
doesn't really have an existence unless
it changes actually that's strangely
similar to what happens in genetic
theory with the sort of theory of gases
that gases aren't a thing like a gas
unless there's Motion in the gas you
know heraclitus perhaps was right in
this idea that you know flow is
everywhere so to speak that you know
there isn't really a sort of an
interesting point I hadn't really
internalized that before that in our
model of physics the notion that space
is continually changing is critical to
the model because space there is no
notion except in the center of a black
hole where there's a space like
similarity there is no notion of time
having stopped if time has stopped
there's no Observer to observe anything
the universe effectively is not is not a
thing that has extent and so on and so
in a sense there is a need for change in
the same sense that heraclitus I think
perhaps talked about it although his
terminology is very different because he
lived 2000 years earlier
um that more than 2500 years earlier
that um
uh you know the possibility of of space
is a consequence of a sort of a flow in
the heraclitus sense in this case uh
sort of of the updating of of the
structure of space through time so in
any case the the
um
back to sort of views of space well
you know people
by the time of Einstein people have
firmly thought space was continuous I
mean Euclid after all had assumed that
space was continuous by just saying
there is geometry now there's an
interesting discussion and Maxwell
actually Maxwell has this in his article
and Encyclopedia Britannica it's really
lovely discussion about the arithmetic
versus the geometric view of of physics
and what he says is in the arithmetic
view there are numbers discrete numbers
now for some reason he wasn't
internalizing kind of the Continuum of
numbers as I might have expected him to
because we've certainly knowing about by
that time uh that was a little bit
before people like dedicant had really
started talking about the the
formalization and the accentization of
real numbers but not too much before
that but in any case he he viewed the
sort of arithmetic view of nature as
being there's a bunch of numbers there's
a bunch of corpuscular distinct
countable things there versus the
geometric view of nature which was more
this plenum this Continuum view that
Euclid had kind of pioneered so he and
he discusses you know the atomic view
Maxwell discusses the atomic view is
much more this arithmetical view of of
nature Okay so
but by the time uh
you know for example Newton is a very
geometrical has a very geometrical point
of view about kind of how things work
and and you know he's his principle here
is very much set up in the style of
Euclid's elements and it's sort of
geometrical derivations of things all
the way so he certainly believed in a
sort of a Continuum of space in the same
sense that Euclid did and by the time
one was and so the traditions of
mechanics that came from Newton and that
eventually led to Maxwell's
electrodynamics which is kind of what
triggered Einstein to try and work out
relativity and to try and and to realize
the correspondences between space and
time and so on in relativity that was
kind of in one on the one hand came out
of the mechanics tradition the calculus
tradition which then turned into the
Maxwell's equations for electromagnetism
tradition that then delivered kind of
the uh this notion of uh of space-time
that Einstein had which which minkowsky
was the one who was really responsible
minkowski Herman minkowsky have been
number theorist and was very big on
quadratic forms and so when he started
seeing the distance between two points
which in euclidean space would be you
know the square root of x squared plus y
squared plus Z squared in the Einstein
case would be x squared plus y squared
plus c squared minus c squared t squared
by C is the speed of light
um and T is time and it's like that's a
quadratic form let's just view space and
time the space coordinates the time
coordinate as being the same kind of
thing so to speak and that's where this
kind of notion of the space-time
Continuum really came from I I happen to
think it was a misleading notion and
because it made space and time seem like
too much the same kind of thing which
they're really not I mean space is this
extent of this hypergraph and time is
the progress of computation by which
things are are transformed so to speak
in a very heraclitian kind of way I
suppose so
I think
um the uh okay so Einstein
um
Einstein did think that space was
probably discreet there's a Letter
People sent me this copy of this letter
many times from 1916 a year after the
developments of general relativity
Einstein says uh I think space is going
to be discreet
or so after he thought about photons
things like that I think space is going
to be discreet but at this time we do
not have the mathematical apparatus to
to talk about that kind of thing
and uh well maybe he was right took 100
more years
um and uh took until we'd understood
this whole stack of things about
computation and graph Theory and
discrete math and and so on to get to
the point where we could really talk
about space-time in a sensible way as
something discrete now somebody's told
me that that Einstein actually
thought had another reason for thinking
space-time might be discreet it's a it's
a curious reason Einstein very early in
in the development of general relativity
knew that there would be gravitational
radiation knew that just like
accelerating charges will radiator
magnetic radiation accelerating masses
and and changing masses will will
radiate gravitational radiation and one
of the things that have been a big
mystery in the theory of the atom was
okay you've got these electrons they're
being held in these orbits but an
electron that goes around an orbit it
emits radiation synchron radiation
whatever it radiates
um and so that would mean that the
electrons should lose energy and they
should spiral into the nucleus and go
Splat but that didn't happen and what
was realized eventually by Bohr and
people like that in the development of
quantum theory was the reason that
doesn't happen is because the energy
levels of the electron are quantized
they're a discrete set of energy levels
and it can't just continuously lose
energy and spiral into the nucleus and
so the speculation about what Einstein
thought was that he thought there was
going to be the same issue with
gravitational radiation why wouldn't
just tiny amounts of gravitational
radiation over immense periods of time
make every electron spiral into its
nucleus and that's a speculation about
why Einstein thought there's got to be a
way to show that it's discrete now in
terms of this discreteness business it's
sort of an interesting thing to know how
do you show that things are discrete and
they're sort of in the 1800s people like
Dalton had given sort of circumstantial
evidence from the fact that you know in
water there's H2O and it's always two
hydrogens one oxygen that sort of
suggests discreetness rather than just
there's a there's a bunch of oxygen and
a bunch of hydrogen the fact that there
are small integers involved suggests
discrete kind of entities but it had
been rather circumstantial and you know
as the 1800s kind of chugged along
people uh tried to get other evidence of
discreetness or or not as the case may
be and I think um uh Lord Rayleigh
William strut
um was uh had one of these where he
basically would pour a tiny put a tiny
drop of oil on top of the surface of
water and see whether lycopodium powder
pollen-like stuff would fall through the
oil into the water because lycopodium
powder gets you know uh pulled in by the
polar molecules and the water sucked in
there but if you put a layer of oil it
can't get through the oil so the
question is if you put that layer of oil
there's a point at which that drop of
oil is spreading out of a region so that
it is so thin it's like you know 100
millionth of a meter thick and at some
point if there is discreetness in the
oil at some point the it will no longer
be able to support the lycopodium powder
and that will drop through and I gather
that that estimate that gave estimates
of the size of atoms that weren't
totally wrong
and so that should have been giving out
evidence by the by the 1880s maybe that
there were that atoms were a real thing
but I'm not sure how well it was
believed I think Lush met I was the
first person to measure the size of an
atom in some way and I think one way of
doing that is using kinetic theory and
using um uh viscosity of gases uh based
on sort of how big the the balls have to
be if they're colliding so to speak
um I haven't yet gotten to that part of
my homework so um I I can't tell you
about the details of that experiment yet
um but another very famous one is is
brown in motion which have been involved
observed by Robert Brown is that his
name back in like the 1830s or so that
you put these pollen grains in water you
look under a microscope and they seem to
be getting kicked around seems like
Einstein was the one who first really
gave a good theory of that and said oh
it's discrete molecules kicking the
things around and so that was another
sort of uh you know absolute nailing
down if there really are molecules but
the question is you know Finding brownie
in motion finding this idea of a thin
layer and knowing that like a Podium
powder drops through or not I need to
find the same kinds of things for the
structure of space and you know the
clever experiments and uh if anybody can
figure these out that'd be terrific the
clever experiments that are just reveal
that see through to the discreetness of
space just like these experiments back
in those days in the late 1800s and so
on saw through to the discreetness of
matter and you know one wonders you know
at that critically spinning black hole
does it just get to the edge where it's
kind of like the the layer of oil and
the lycopodium powder and so on but I
don't know about the lycopodium powder
is for the black hole and I don't know
um and you know unfortunately scientific
history does repeat to some extent but
it doesn't or it doesn't precisely
repeat and when one does know the
experiment that proves that space is
discrete one will be kind of kicking
oneself oh that was really an obvious
experiment that could have been done I
bet that the experiment that shows that
space is discrete could have been done
uh
I'm going to guess 50 years before it
actually is when we finally figured out
what what the correct experiment is
we'll see
it might also be something where you
have to really reach to get to the
experiment
but uh um you know I I am very amused as
I read about caloric and uh the
substance that is supposed to be heat
and where is it oh it's everywhere well
though it gets through things oh it does
this and that and the other I'm deeply
reminded of dark matter which is another
kind of thing where people say oh we
don't know what it is maybe it's in the
Earth's crust maybe it's in the center
of stars maybe it's uh floating out
wherever we can't quite detect it but it
has an effect same thing with caloric it
has an effect it's hot but we can't
quite detect it we can't quite put it in
a bottle for example
um it has an amusing sort of historical
uh resonance I would say we'll see we'll
see how dark matter turns out
um and we'll see whether it turns out to
be something that is something about the
structure of space-time that is a little
bit more bizarre just like caloric heat
is really a property of matter that's a
little bit more bizarre than people have
thought it's not or there's just
something dissolved in the matter it's
the the matter itself is in motion in a
way that that hadn't been understood
before
so you know what what happened with the
quantization of spaces Einstein kind of
talked about it said we don't have the
tools to study it by the 1930s people
were quantizing everything and people
did try and quantize space and tried to
figure out what that could work and they
couldn't make it consistent with
relativity they couldn't make something
where space is a bunch of a box says or
something that are quantized and um uh
and and but those boxes when you when
you look at them uh in different
reference frames you look at them you
know you're going at eight times the 0.8
of the speed of light or something
um those boxes will be distorted and
nobody could figure out sort of a way to
make that Distortion work in a way that
was not uh that was invariant under
autistic that was appropriate under
relativistic Transformations we finally
have such a way
um as a in the causal graphs of our sort
of update
mechanism for hypographs and so on we
have exactly something like that
that is relativistically invariant it's
a discrete model of space-time that's
relativistically invariant but to get to
it you have to go sort of below the
notion of space uh that that has
normally been thought about
and uh that wasn't something that was
was understood before people had
wondered about things like oh is is
space discrete that's a little bit hard
to measure is time discrete that's a
little bit easier to measure because
there are particles a whole gaggle of
particles discovered around 1960 that
decay in 10 to minus 24 seconds and
people were trying to say oh well maybe
you know if the discreetness length is 3
times 10 to the minus 5 to 25 seconds
then oh we'll see discrete levels of
lifetimes for those particles those were
not observed
um but that was sort of an attempt to um
to find discreetness and time in that
case
let's see oh boy sorry I went on about
these things a long time but uh
um
somebody's saying uh they're very
interested to hear about the future
History of Science well I'll have lots
to say about second world feminomics
soon
um for those who really want to watch
the the paint drying process I I do make
this video Work logs of what I do every
day
um and you can see it gradually grow but
it's probably incomprehensible because
it's just what I'm Computing and so on
um and uh it'll get coherent later you
know I was thinking about sort of the
future of uh things like you know
caloric and and a lot of these things
where we say that was a crazy idea the
Alchemists all these kinds of things and
I was thinking to myself
um what what are the things that we
think today that will just seem bizarre
in the future and I think one of the
things that we're really beginning to
understand today is something about the
extent to which
the the small can build up to the very
different so to speak so you know the
whole thing that I've studied about
simple programs that can do very
complicated things the whole notion that
you can have things that are microscopic
scale that produce lots of large-scale
effect the whole notion in our physics
project one of the things that was a
sort of psychological thing for me to
get over in the physics project or a
sort of paradigmatic thing to get over
is that our universe is an unbelievably
profligate waster of computation
I didn't really think that I thought our
universe is just Computing the way the
universe works but it isn't it's
Computing just this unbelievable tree of
possibilities which we conflate together
to be the threat of experience that we
have but it's unbelievably wasteful
computationally it's just you know
gobbling up it is just running all this
computation most of which just nobody
cares about there's no you know no
Observer to observe it it just is
Computing Computing and what's sort of
interesting is as we kind of go pull
back from this just unbelievably huge
amount of computation that's going on
and we see the little things that are
floating it's like the water molecules
in the water and all we see is the Eddy
on the surface of the water it's it's
the the things that emerge from all that
activity underneath and I think that the
realization that there's more activity
underneath and a bigger distance to what
emerges for us is one of the things that
will be something that people say well
well of course just like after molecules
were known of course water is made of a
bunch of molecules but if somebody had
said that before when they say and how
many molecules are there in there there
are Avogadro's number of molecules you
know 10 to the 23 you know 10 to 24
molecules that's just crazy that's way
too many we say how many computational
operations are there going on in the
universe it's 10 to the 10 to the 400.
say that's just crazy that's just too
many but I think that won't be those
things won't seem crazy in the future
um I think that there are well a lot of
different things that I think will be uh
kind of features of the of the view of
the future
um another one that's sort of a an easy
one is you know this notion that today
we have things made of materials in the
future people will be surprised that
everything wasn't made of computers that
it wasn't the case that everything down
to the molecular scale was programmable
that we just had dumb materials where we
just had a you know a piece of plastic
so to speak as opposed to a thing that
is running computation in its very
molecules so to speak and you know I
think that there are uh in in terms of
things about science I I think that the
um uh this whole well something which is
coming very soon is the importance of
computational irreducibility and the
notion of what might be predictable in
science and what might not be
predictable in science what the
boundaries of science really are that's
something which uh in the next I don't
know
20 50 100 years people will understand
that and they'll understand that there
are things that science can say and
predict and there are things where
science just says well can't really
figure that out you've got to watch it
and see what happens because what you
can figure out you could simulate it but
you won't really do any better than just
having the thing happen itself you might
be able to have sort of a digital twin
of the thing but you can't have
something which is just going to jump
ahead and see the answer so you know I
think and there are probably things
about the importance of the Observer and
how that relates to the science that one
observes I I found it I saw an
interesting letter that Einstein wrote
um about um
which really uh kind of
uh it's like in the there are knowing no
new ideas Under the Sun so to speak but
um uh it was to a person who was an
Enthusiast of Von frischer's work on
beads
and um the question I think was you know
bees can sense the polarization of light
in the sky and there was a bunch of
question about that and somebody wrote
to Einstein about this and and Einstein
was sort of writing about how well there
might be things that bees or dogs or
whatever can sense that we can't
um and somehow was talking about the
kind of the different physics that might
be uh observable to those kind of
Critters and that that's very much like
the whole story of different points in
rural space and alien intelligence and
so on that I've been talking about
recently so I was I was interested to
see that that was um a uh a thing
um
let's see
um
okay there's a bunch of questions here
let me let me try and um
uh
neems is asking what was the most
fantastic experience you had as a
physicist
um
had a bunch of decent ones when I was a
kid
and then I had a great one recently
which was the stuff about our our Theory
of physics and the probably the single
most remarkable thing was the
realization that general relativity and
the payment path integral are the same
thing but operating in different kinds
of space that that's really kind of as
far as I'm concerned just a super cool
thing and uh interestingly because we
were doing this sort of an open science
project probably the very moment where
we realized that is actually captured on
uh you know somebody actually go back
and say oh it took these guys a really
long time they had to spend hours and
hours talking about this and then
finally it finally it became clear
um you know back when I was a kid doing
physics
I would say the thing I've always liked
is When Things become much clearer when
there's a sort of a mass of stuff and
you manage to boil it down to something
very clean very very direct and then the
early work that I did on the mixture
this is 1978 or so on the interface
between cosmology and particle physics
there was a lot of hair there a lot of
complicated stuff and I was pretty
pleased to be able to boil it down into
this sort of very clean notion of
statistical mechanics general relativity
and cosmology and particle physics
actually the you know really using the
three big theories of 20th century
physics
um but being able to make that very
clean was something I I found really
quite quite neat
um but uh I would say that the um
the thing that has been rather
unrewarding I would say is you make
predictions and then people observe them
and it's kind of like you think that
will be like that will be super cool you
know you make a prediction you just
think it through and then somebody does
the physical experiment and then they
say well you're right
at least in my experiences in particle
physics the story was just much much
muddier than that it was a prediction I
made that would disagreed with an
experiment that already existed the
experiment was redone my prediction was
right
you know not exactly a ticker tape
parade so to speak it was kind of a uh
oh okay
um rather muddy not not the drama that
you might think of in a kind of um uh
you know papyrian version of science
where it's like it's falsifiable no it's
actually true we did the experiment
actual science doesn't work that way
actual science experiments are hard you
don't know they're right you need a
whole interpretation framework sometimes
the interpretation framework seeps into
the analysis of the experiment it's a
complicated story it's not a clean you
know it's not a clean sort of
competitive thing where you say I wager
that the world works this way and
somebody says okay you win
um it's it's a much more complicated
kind of story
um
well let's see
uh
the question from Mikhail here what's
the history behind migrating the entropy
term to information Theory
so
I I think
you know what happened
is that
boltzmann
uh
talked about
the number of states of a system and
said the entropy which have been defined
by clausius in terms of of heat and
temperature he said the entropy
is equal to K constant now called
boltzman's constant log Omega where
Omega is the number of states actually
he called it w
um
now
the fact that that's true is basically
what's happening is that
if you as soon as you believe equal
partition as soon as you believe that
every degree of Freedom has an equal
average amount of energy a half KT of
energy for example where T is
temperature then Q over T is essentially
a counting of the number of degrees of
freedom the number of molecules the
number of ways things can twist whatever
else something that can have energy
associated with it
and then the the number of states
is you know let's say you have particles
in a box and you have them in discrete
little sub boxes it's how do you arrange
the particles in all the sub boxes and
that's your Omega and the log of that
counts the number of particles
um now for boltzmann that was a
complicated thing because he couldn't
count particles like that because he
didn't know the world was made of
particles people said it's a continuum
but he invented particles he invented
the idea that there would be atoms and
that the atoms will be in discrete
places in space with discrete velocities
Planck when he came to to think about
black body radiation photons was
extremely well aware of Boltzmann's work
because Planck was primarily a
thermodynamics person was writing
textbooks about thermodynamics and so on
so what Planck really did was to say
actually that thing that boltzmann just
said was a mathematical fiction is
reality um Einstein kind of came behind
that really so sort of backing that up
but um
the thing that so boltzmann had this
idea of the the K log Omega thing and if
you sort of take different probabilities
for those States for boltzmann you get
the P log P formula that is the same
formula
so then
when Shannon Claude Shannon this is
1940-ish
was studying
um well okay so this history is Muddy
and I don't think it's all understood
yet
uh Claude Shannon during the second
world war worked I think through ATT
worked on speech and cipherment I mean
he Shannon was for a long time at Bell
Labs but he worked on speech
ensipherment
and uh meanwhile Alan Turing in England
was working at Bletchley Park on on
cryptanalysis and one of Alan turing's
big sort of breakthroughs had to do with
understanding better the statistics of
codes
and Alan Turing went to visit
uh
well the speech ensipherment effort and
Claude Shannon in early 1940s I'm not
sure exactly which date in New York City
which is where the Bell Labs was at that
time
nobody knows really what happened there
and it is a remarkable coincidence that
turing's kind of view of the sort of
probabilistic way of thinking about
encryption would dovetail so closely
with Shannon's information Theory I
don't know what happened there I don't
know what the what the sort of
trafficking ideas was whether maybe they
were just uh independently had but this
notion of um uh of the number of
possibilities which is a very
cryptologically important thing the
number of possible keywords and so on is
something that in you know touring was
really interested for very
boltzmann-like in about boltzmann like
we're measuring the log of that the
number of degrees of freedom the number
of independent sort of rotors that you
can turn and things like this
um not quite thinking about it that way
but that's sort of what that comes from
and then so that that in any case
by whatever means Shannon ended up with
uh with this idea of sort of the p-logp
view of entropy and I think there's a
story that um uh Von Neumann John Von
Neumann said to Shannon uh when he was
when Shannon was talking about this
amount of information thing said oh you
should talk about it as entropy or minus
entropy because then everybody will sort
of uh just agree with you because nobody
wants nobody really understands entropy
and um I I don't know if that story is
apocryphal or not
um but that's uh
um and and really the the interplay
between sort of the information Theory
version of things and the uh
statistical mechanics version has taken
a long time to develop I mean those are
really two very different disciplines
only with modern Quantum information
Theory have they really merged in any
serious way I mean there was a lot of
obsession with the thermodynamics of
computation things like Von Neiman
believed that to do a computation
inevitably takes uh the dissipation of
heat
and then Ross landauer was at IBM was a
person who long pushed for that um that
to not be the the case and then Charles
Bennett uh also at IBM Charles Bennett
had been a molecular Dynamics person
um and um he worked out this idea that
you could make a reversible computer and
then Ed fredkin and other people and Tom
tofully and people like that got into
that act as well uh somewhat
independently
um Ed Fred Kim because he wanted a sort
of model computationally things in
physics and people liked it Feynman had
told him physics is reversible you've
got to have something reversible in
computation as well and so all of those
people and this is now in the um uh
1970s mid 1970s
um were kind of um coming up with ways
that you could have instead of instead
of having you know and of p and Q turn
into a single bit which is not
reversible because from that single bit
you can't deduce what the two inputs
were of having a two to two gate and
these are what get used in Quantum
Information Systems all the time now but
that was sort of a place where sort of
the informational thing started started
mixing with statistical mechanics but
didn't really happen in a serious way I
would say until the 90s or or later
let's see
um
should go soon here but uh
um
well all kinds of interesting comments
here
uh Parker's asking what's the process
like making computations for the
thermodynamics a project
uh there haven't been very elaborate
calculations mostly the computations the
fanciest one has to do with Computing
the entropy of space-time and a toy
version and that's taken a few weeks of
CPU time but it's not um we've not not
been not been as Extreme as some of the
other things we've done
um
well let's see maybe I can tackle one
more thing here
um
uh
a lot of interesting questions here
which I know would take me too long to
talk about
[Music]
um
okay Satoshi here is asking what do you
think about engineering efforts that
help discovering science building tools
and experiments I've met many scientists
who dismiss engineering as less
intellectual
look here's the story both of my life
under the history of science
which is it's a cycle between the
development of technology and the
development of basic science technology
develops tools that let you see a new
thing in basic science and the basic
science eventually lets you develop the
tools that give you Tech that give you
technology and so on and in my own life
I've I've done the cycle maybe five or
six times of going from Tool development
to then enabling certain developments of
some basic science then realizing that
that basic science can be used to build
another generation of tools and so on
that is the history of science I mean
that has been for uh you know well
certainly solidly 500 years and arguably
much longer than that the story of the
history of science is this alternation
between the development of tools and the
development of of the kind of uh pure
abstraction of basic science now you
know the way that scientific communities
work
is something where people say look the
only thing that matters is this
particular devotional activity so to
speak is this particular kind of thing
that we do and everything else is
irrelevant now you know I noticed that
even when it comes to I don't know
making uh this is the thing where the
Paradigm you have the way of thinking
you have determines what you think
matters and everything else doesn't I
mean to give a very mundane and trivial
example I'm going through some of my own
archives and uh there's places where we
scan documents and um the you know there
was a FedEx envelope very early FedEx
envelope actually from the early 1980s
um uh looked amazingly similar to a
FedEx envelope today but in any case a
fair example where the content had been
scanned but the person who was doing the
scanning why would anybody care about
the envelope you know that's not the
point well it turned out was the point
for me because the envelope had an air
bill which had a date which allowed me
to date when certain documents have been
produced and so on
um but so it's the same thing for a lot
of stuff people study is you know
without a framework you don't know what
to study but also
there's a question of sort of what
matters so in a study oh like good
example in mathematics right now is
people generate they write down theorems
they write papers with lots of theorems
and maybe they've been four million
theorems written down in the history of
human mathematics but the question of
what the statistical properties of that
whole gas of theorems really is well
nobody studied that that's this field of
empirical matter mathematics that I've
done a little bit on but that's
something where nobody would really care
I mean it's like oh there's a whole
bunch of theorems over in the stretch
and I don't care that there are more
theorems there than there are there well
until there's a theory that allows you
to say something on the basis of that
now so what tends to happen is within a
field of science and it happens even
within a specific field of science it's
like all that matters is
the thing that is defined to matter by
that field of science now a good example
actually let's take machine learning as
an example there were people who wrote
papers about machine learning for well
back to the 1940s for sure
and mostly these are pretty unreadable
mostly they're very engineering kinds of
things oh you can do this Hack That does
this and does that well now of course
last decade machine learning is all the
rage although most of what is really
being done in machine learning is look
at this engineering thing we did it
produces these results there isn't
really a basic intellectual theory of
machine learning there are ideas and
there are ideas that give intuition for
engineering but there isn't really a
sort of a theoretical framework like
that and it's sort of interesting to see
that that the that there are sort of not
academic academicizable aspects in fact
when Fields go through this phase of
becoming academic sort of an interesting
thing I mean it's like you know the
trades all kinds of different trades
from you know blacksmiths to to I don't
know Carpenters to whatever else
uh you know there are things to know in
all of those fields but they're not
really academic things to know I don't
think people I mean they probably do now
but you know write papers about
carpentry it's not a field like that
even when you invent some new kind of
you know wood join or something I don't
think people write you know I'm sure
they do now write academic papers but
that's not the primary way in which
knowledge is communicated is not this
kind of this Academy type based uh
communication of knowledge and I think
in a lot of these areas of engineering I
mean like take software engineering for
example uh you know people will teach
courses about software engineering some
are sensible some are a complete waste
of time because really software
engineering is mostly about sort of it's
not it's not a story of facts it's a
story of skills and experience and
actually doing it and knowing yourself
and knowing how you do certain kinds of
things and so on and it's not something
where you know memorize these facts
about software engineering isn't really
you know I I'm sure I'm horrified to
imagine there probably are well okay
here's an example of something that is
not academized yet is language design
thing that I've spent much of my life
doing is the process of of sort of
constructing the functional design of a
computational language
it's not I don't think there are I don't
know if there are nobody ever showed me
any academic papers about those things
maybe people have studied things I've
done maybe not they I don't know I know
people have used some of the things we
do on on our uh live streams doing
software design as things for software
engineering classes but that's a little
bit of a different thing but you know
there is a body of knowledge and
certainly within our organization we've
developed quite a body of knowledge
about sort of how to do how to do
computational language design but it's
not something for which there is a you
know an academic kind of published
papers type type structure same with
playing with most of software
engineering I mean and you know
sometimes these fields uh even you know
things one has built at an engineering
level one looks years later and people
have kind of made a course out of doing
something like that and you realize that
the real Meats of the software
engineering is you know other than just
saying well you know it becomes like a
history course it's like this is what
happened this is what these people did
not this is the generalized version of
that I think I suppose the generalized
you know history is about sort of what
happened and so on and I suppose one
could one could ask you know is there a
similar kind of course about how to
change history well if you're in a
military academy maybe or if you're
doing uh you know some kind of political
thing or some management thing maybe
there is
um but it's kind of a a you know there's
what has been done which is very
academic academicizable and there's you
know the kind of the the artisanal work
of what you do next and any case so so I
mean these fields where there's very
academic traditions and they're the ones
whether or not and it is and you know in
Academia for example oh I don't know you
know if you write a program that's used
by a million people
and you write a paper that's read by
five people
uh you know it could be the case that
for your tenure review the paper is what
matters the program nobody cares about
that's a feature of you know it depends
what you care about it depends what you
think matters is it the is it the
contents of the FedEx envelope or is it
the envelope itself type thing you know
or whatever I mean it's the same thing
that happens with people who are
involved with collecting systematic data
in different kinds of fields they
usually have usually in many fields they
have low Kudos in that field in some
Fields they're the King of the Hill
um and uh uh you know in some Fields
where where you know I think for example
in in
bioinformatics the um well maybe that's
not quite happened that way but they're
Fields where the aggregation of large
amounts of data is the most dramatic
thing that's going on and the people who
are doing it are kind of the um uh you
know the top dogs and there are other
fields where it's like oh yeah they're
those people in the back room who
collect data in our field and you know
they're just staff scientists and
they're you know they're the people who
are hangers on at the universities and
we don't care about them and the people
we really care about are the professors
who are publishing papers
now you know is that the right attitude
no I mean it's you know but this is this
is what happens in kind of developed
Fields where there's a lot of
stratification and and uh and
specialization in the different roles
and you know Academia has a particular
specialization in this particular
workflow of write about something that
you can write a paper about well you may
develop a piece of software that's
unbelievably useful but writing a paper
about it what would you say
I mean it's kind of funny I realized
recently I wrote some some things about
the development of SMP the uh the
precursor of open language and
Mathematica
um and I realize I'm not sure people
wrote about software development I mean
I I wrote about kind of the the
conceptual design of the system
um a little bit not too much but um uh
sort of intellectualizing something
which I think had been as often just a
pure you know artisanal kind of activity
so it is an interesting point that um
and you know if you ask the question
well just to give an example when
computer science became really popular
in the 80s and 90s uh and universities
you know realized oh my gosh we have all
these students who want to study
computer science we don't have any
professors to teach it to teach it
there was this kind of big pull to get
practitioners in to be professors people
who had been software Engineers you know
out in the field so to speak doing stuff
and it's like okay now can you teach
this well a lot of what that led to was
more kind of uh trades teaching so to
speak of you know I've written programs
I'll teach you how to write programs too
it didn't really intellectualize that
much but there was sort of a and perhaps
that's a you know that's been and I
don't know well uh you know it's an
interesting question how much
intellectualization of for example
teaching software engineering should
there be because it's it's like you know
if you teach somebody a language French
you know English writing how much should
you just teach this is what you do this
is what the words are and how much
should you start saying and this is how
you can diagram your sentence and see
that you know to boldly go is a split
infinitive which you can see you know in
the parse tree has you know a verb
phrase that has a
um uh you know an adverb Stuck in the
Middle as opposed to an adverb as a as a
A pre-verb or whatever it is you know
who knows the the um in other words how
much do you teach just the doing and how
much you're trying to teach the theory
of the doing and is there even a
credible theory of the doing and is it
in fact the case that people uh find it
useful who are learning something find
it useful you know one of the things
I've noticed is that in teaching woven
language for example
um I uh have noticed and I I haven't
done very much of this recently but I
did a bunch of experiments a number of
years ago uh with uh with kids my my
efforts with kids these days seem to be
talking about things more General than
the specifics of of programming but um
uh the things that um
uh I noticed is that if you try and
teach the theory first
for almost all kids that's a hopeless
proposition
uh the only kids for whom it is not is
my theory is those are the kids that
will grow up to be pure mathematicians
and things like that there are some
people whose turn of mind is just give
me the structure it can be as abstract
as you want and then I'll fill things
into that structure for most of us
including myself for example it's like
just show me some examples of how things
work so I get an intuition for what's
going on and once I've seen some
examples then I can kind of build up
this abstraction layer on top of that
and then I'll understand the abstraction
layer but um uh you know I think that
that's again with respect to the
teaching of things and and the what
matters question you know the
abstraction can be very austere uh and
very incomprehensible without kind of
the the actual examples and so when you
try and take something that is
essentially an engineering type of thing
and uh and and you try and say and now I
want to abstractify it you'll end up
with this incredibly austere and
incomprehensible abstractified version
of it that may or may not be useful
sometimes what happens is that you go
sort of up to the abstraction and then
back down again to the practicality and
I mean certainly in my own life that's
an activity that I've done many times is
is you take the big Blobby mess you
drill down you find those those
Primitives often very abstract relatives
that that are underneath the big Lobby
mass and you build back up again and
then you realize it isn't so big and
Blobby after all there's actually ways
you can structure it and ways you can
make a lot of progress and understanding
what's going on and building useful
things from it and that that's been you
know for me personally that's been very
much my my personal sort of Discovery
and invention workflow
so but but I think it's it's a it's a
fair observation
um that uh
um
the uh
um
uh that that
um
this sort of downgrading of the tool
Builders at least by the quotes
intellectuals I mean to be clear
tool building is a deeply intellectual
activity just a little different from
the kind of intellectual activity that
is the things that people write academic
papers about I mean I would say that for
example you know the language design
process is you know I worked on a bunch
of intellectually fairly demanding
things that is probably the single most
uniformly intellectually demanding thing
that I I've ever tried to do and I've
I've been doing it now for 40 years so
so I've developed some ability to do it
by this point
um you know I I noticed this um uh from
memes computational language design is
being like being a modern day wizard
yeah yeah you're defining well it's it
people don't yet understand the
importance of it I mean one day people
will understand because it is the it is
the framework that defines how one
thinks about things and that's kind of
the most Upstream kind of thing in
intellectual work is to define the
framework for thinking about things and
it's a very general kind of very broad
way of doing that you know in talking
about modern times Wizardry I I am
one of my kids had a computer disaster
day before yesterday and I was uh
um talking to them on the phone about uh
you know a computer that just refused to
you know uh
charge from the power outlets and so on
and I'm realizing I'm looking up you
know how do you reset the uh system
memory
system what is it called memory
controller I think on on a Mac the SMC
thing on a Mac how do you reset the the
non-volatile RAM and things like this
and it's just crazy because you know the
things you do you know you hold down
three keys and you press another key for
seven seconds and um you're doing these
other things you're letting things up
this is you know if somebody said what
do the shamans do what do the um uh you
know what do the kind of um incantations
evolve by the uh by the Wizards and
witches and so on what were those all
about it's like just see the modern
engineering design of uh of computers
and their boot sequences and things and
that is sort of the modern version of
this and it really is quite a strange
thing I mean it's kind of like a
incomprehensible thing but holding down
that combination of keys well the thing
is booting when it's doing this for some
number of seconds it's it's kind of I I
just find it interesting that there are
these processes and and phenomena that
are just sort of have Arisen many times
in the history of of uh in human history
and that they have such similarity and
that they're they're you know now
obviously there is a certain Resonance
of we know it was done that way
historically but there's also a certain
Resonance of we're still humans and we
still sort of uh biologically very much
the same as we were 100 200 000 years
ago and so there are certain things that
sort of are natural to US based on our
our biology so to speak anyway I don't
know whether not sure I can quite uh tie
it all the way from the weird key
combinations for for booting Max in safe
mode or something and um versus uh
uh uh versus the incantations of um uh
you know when you have this big cauldron
that you're that you're um uh pouring
things into all right I think um
uh to go in here gosh so many
interesting things this is always a fun
conversation I wish it was more I wish
it could be even more interactive but we
don't really have a good mechanism for
that uh Zayden is commenting technology
science social relations all co-evolve
yeah I think that's true I mean I think
that the um uh
uh you know it's it's also another thing
that you see a lot in the history of
science is the pre-discovery somebody
discovered something and they were
ignored and um you know I've certainly
seen that in my own life of things I've
discovered and nobody nobody paid
attention to it
um and uh for a long time and then I
think what happens is there's an
encroaching of kind of socially
understood stuff that eventually
encroaches close enough you can kind of
tunnel through the barrier and then sort
of there is General understanding of
what um of the of the core thing that
was discovered and and sometimes that
takes a hundred years or more for the
kind of the general understanding sort
of the bubbling understanding to get
close enough that you can kind of see
through that the that the the new thing
is kind of reachable from that
socialized understanding so to speak and
when it isn't reachable it's kind of
like well I could start just making up
English words and saying them and nobody
would understand them and it's like
until those words have become a little
bit familiar uh what was a word that I
just saw recently uh well I saw a word
recently which uh Francis Bacon used
ah gosh what was it
questions or something I'm not sure but
it meant um
the essence of something somehow
um at least by context that's all it
must have meant
but in any case I mean that there are
words that sort of you know just about
make it into I like the word chain for
example okay we sort of might think we
know what a chain means but then there's
blockchain and then there's a completely
new kind of meaning of the word chain
when you hear chain in certain kinds of
settings uh you have a completely
different cognitive framework now than
you might have done you know 20 years
ago
um and uh you know that's an example
sort of the encroachment of of sort of
uh ambient ideas onto the ability to
explain a particular thing all right I
need to need to go here but um thanks
for joining me and um uh maybe I'll have
done more of my homework
um by next time and be able to tell you
more about the uh the history of
thermodynamics and um and things like
that
but um until then well bye for now